you had a very exciting moment and
you're already you're such a new fresh
young career but you've had a highlight
already tell us what was I have you were
recently mentioned on a certain show yes
this was your reminder so I'm told
clearly it had no effect at all this was
a moment for real it was every friend
texted me I grew up watching this show
so yeah I got a shout-out on Family Guy
recently vaguely I shout out this
respect that it was a kind of a moment
we're like five different friends text
me were like this is the moment that
you've made it you are now you're now
famous so what happen this show yeah and
then your friends tell you they actually
mentioned you yeah it has got to be a
moment where you realize okay things are
things are good yeah I was full-on
name-drop yeah it was pretty cool oh
it's Stewie who mentions yes Dewey
actually was his his coming out mentions
that you know he's not fully gay but if
he does think that he'd make a cute
Instagram couple with Grant Gustin oh
yeah yeah thank you
oh by the way he's a big admirer of the
male form
I just say something yeah story would
make just as much sense with your shirt
off
not if you were looking at him on a bus
that way I'd have you arrested you know
we have your Family Guy clip I think we
should see it playing if anything I'm
less gay than I used to be hope that
anybody at this school would care but do
I think that Grant Gustin and I would
make the most adorable Instagram couple
yes yes we would
Grant Gustin plays the flash on the CW
if you were wondering because you know
most people over 70 probably don't know
who he is
[Applause]
you